استهداف صاروخي روسي مكثف لمدن ومواقع
اوكرانيه الجيش الاوكراني اكد انه تمكن من
اسقاط 34 صاروخا من اصل واحد وثمانين
صاروخا اطلقتها القوات الروسيه هنا حيوه
استيقظ على وقع الضربات الروسيه وتحت صدمه
السكان
لقد تعبت حقا من كل هذا لم اعد اتحمل هذا
الوضع
لا افهم كيف يفعلون هذا انهم ليسوا بشرا
لا اعرف حتى ماذا اسميهم انهم يخيفون
الاطفال لقد تعبت حالتهم النفسيه
ايقظني الانفجار كان انفجارا مدويا لم اكن
لاتخيل ان هذا سيحدث في حيي قبل مغادره
المنزل سمعت في الاخبار ان النيران اشعلت
في سيارات عده عندما خرجت ادركت ان هذه
السيارات كانت خلف فناء بيتي
المشهد نفسه في الفيف دمار واسع في
المدينه بعد قصف روسيه اصاب مناطق سكنيه
في مدينه اوديسا اكد الحاكم انه هجوما
صاروخيا اصاب منشاه للطاقه مما ادى الى
قطع التيار الكهربائي كما اصيبت مناطق
سكنيه لكن لم ترد انباء عن سقوط ضحايا
من جهته قال حاكم منطقه خركيف ان المدينه
تعرضت ل 15 ضربه جويه في اعقاب هذه
الضربات الروسيه انقطع التيار الكهربائي
عن محطه زابوريا النوويه وهي تعمل حاليا
على مولدات الديزل حسب المسؤولين المحليين